okay i know we ran into each other a
long time ago the today show and i was i
literally left the room and my whole
team was like you're insane i was so
excited
i meant crazy i was keeping my cool but
like when i left you played it great i i
am now beside myself to meet you because
i've since gotten madly into the voice
oh and every time we watch it at home
and every time you say anything and you
do your dance and you have this face
that you do when you're like really
liking something
and i turn to john every time i go i
think she's my best friend i think we're
supposed to be best friends i want to be
best friends i love you um so have you
ever done a rubik's cube did you see the
rubix thing earlier so i'm waiting for
my portrait i'm kind of excited about
the idea of getting my own portrait i
don't know i was like isn't that extreme
i can't do one he does like a hundred
and puts them perfectly and yeah it's it
was it was amazing i've never been able
to do one not life never and and then i
remember someone a kid was like oh well
that's you just have to and i'm like
well it feels like you're cheating how
you're telling me to do it like there's
and i don't want to cheat
i think there's some kind of trick
because they were trying to tell me but
i hate cheating as you will find out
later when we immediately this is what i
hear that you're a major major gamer you
know what i'm a major gamer in real life
and i'm amazing on this show
you saw there's a big wall of champions
that beat me
it's like been the person that you
couldn't believe they beat you
i mean i couldn't i couldn't well the
freaking guy who started it blake i was
like how does he when he hates games
yeah and he went but they did golden
girls and i was more of a designing
woman myself so like i like like that
was more my show so he beat me at that
whatever but we'll see how my laws goes
i'm gonna kick your ass but anyway yeah
[Music]